you know how they say it's dirty  politics is dirty okay well if there's  anybody that's gonna know if it is or if  it isn't so is it dirtier than you  thought or is it dirty as is exactly  what you how dirty you thought it was  going to be well when i went there i  knew it was a swamp  uh i found that it was worse than that  it's a cesspool  can you unpack that you know examples of  why you think it is well for instance i  was  convinced that  if i became secretary of housing and  urban development  we would be able to put forward programs  that would allow people  through their own efforts to climb out  of poverty  and i said that everybody should be  on board with this and i was pretty  amazed  with how vehemently opposed  some people on the hill were to people  becoming  independent  because if people become independent you  can't control their votes